welcome back our next guest is a
wildflower who lives a dual life she's a
sanitation worker for the city of new
york by day
and a beauty pageant contestant in her
free time when you see her you will
understand why
she is from staten island new york
please welcome the clean queen nicole
does
hi thank you so much for having me thank
you so much for coming here
what a polarity
multifaceted life you live
you keep the city clean you're really
passionate about this
tell me why and how you go about it
yes so i started as a sanitation worker
which means that yeah i was physically
picking up garbage every day so that
would be almost approximately 12 tons a
day if not more and i also drive a
street sweeper like what was the
catalyst
so my dad is actually a sanitation
worker also and i really just wanted to
be able to support myself and i knew it
was a male dominated field but i said if
i can do it why can't i i want to
support myself i want to be able to
stand on my own two feet in the city and
what better way than doing this not only
is it male dominated even when it comes
to like the uniforms you kind of had to
struggle there right oh yeah so even now
there's only about 200 women and there's
about 7 000 sanitation workers and at
the time when i first started working
there were no female clothing so i
actually had male pants tailored to me
in order just to go to work every single
day thankfully we've come very far so we
have female pants now i get to wear my
lady pants to work but yeah it was it
was a struggle that i wasn't necessarily
prepared for at the beginning
oh my god i'm so in awe of everything
that you're saying
i'd also like to learn from you because
we get told these
really
you know sometimes scary facts about
recycling what can we do to recycle
better
how does it function what do you need
from us
please teach us
just to be vigilant you know there's a
lot of things that can be recycled that
you wouldn't necessarily assume could be
but on the flip side of that there are a
lot of things that need to be recycled
in very specific ways okay we have some
um examples over here
in my personal house i want to learn
from you teach me so we have here we've
got our metal this is twinfoil and a lot
of people would naturally assume that
it's garbage you know you've got your
food on it things like that i would
suggest rinse it off you can recycle
this this would be considered metal
really absolutely
right in your plastic metal how
important is cleaning a vessel for the
recycling bin i would absolutely suggest
to rinse off your products as much as
you can because all of that organic
matter on the inside sometimes we're not
able to take it if it's contaminated for
recycling so always do your best to try
to clear things out if you're like a jar
of peanut butter for example you know
clean that all out but you know whatever
you can do is always helpful okay next
yes so we have here
right over here we have a container of
milk
a lot of people would assume that
because it's made of a cardboard type of
material that it's paper it's not this
is also recycled with your plastic and
metal because on the inside it's lined
with plastic
so that's why you recycle this with your
plastic and metal
okay okay so carton but treat it as
plastic yes okay
what is this
so that is tissue paper you hear the
word paper so you would automatically
assume it's recyclable this is something
we like to call wish cycling
something we really really hope is
recyclable but unfortunately it's not
because of the way it's made this is
something we're not able to recycle so
that's something that would go in the
trash what are these and i mean i know
what they are but why are they here
these can be recycled with your paper
and they should be because cardboard is
so easily recyclable
okay so these go in the recycling not
your little trash can now you're
recycling all right well thank you i did
not know that and that it's going to
change my life what are these guys doing
so
another wish cycling item they're glass
so we're automatically going to assume
they're going to go into your plastic
metal glass bin but they don't
unfortunately that's trash what's the
difference different types of materials
of glass it's just
particulars as far as recycling goes all
right well this has been like honestly
so educational for me i
i really really
really appreciate it now sit back down
for one more minute i want to ask you as
we close out our discussion give me the
pm beauty queen perspective what is that
life like
that is my glamorous side and i love
every bit of it i've been competing in
pageants since i was about 18. it took
me a long time until i finally won one
it took about six years or so but uh i
love it because i get to promote
something that's important to me and
environmentalism and living a zero waste
lifestyle is important to me and it's
really fun that i've been able to mesh
together these two really different
lifestyles into something really
wonderful
[Music]
you know that song like i'm every woman
i think it was written about you thank
you thank you so much for coming on this
show
and being who you are and teaching what
you teach and being the example i'm
mesmerized by you thank you so much
nicole thank you
[Music]